well it was you know typical of a really
interesting development in that I was
looking for something else and and you
know it was it it was a like PCR with
the possible outcome of a solution to a
hypothetical problem that didn't really
exist I mean I was working on trying to
sequence a single base pair you know
think why they call snips today single
nucleotide polymorphisms because those
were medically important and I was
trying to do it with Oleg and
nucleotides because I ran a lab that
made them and we had really improved the
efficiency with which we made them over
the three or four years prior so that we
were making we can make him a lot faster
than the company see just I worked for
could use them I had seven people
working for me and I was thinking well
I'm either gonna have to cut the staff
down to like about three because now we
got these little automated devices they
don't do that or I'm gonna have to
increase the demand for all your
nucleotides so I started thinking of
what else can you do with them and I
thought that it's possible that you can
make a rapid clinical assay for single
base polymorphisms
like sickle cell anemia was a good
example out people there that took back
then maybe you'd go into a clinic and
they take a sample and maybe three weeks
later you know it's just
lonna veganizing now though you're gonna
be nice to have been one shift the
hospital can go in and they'd let you
know and I I thought oligonucleotides
maybe were the answer there but I was
really I I was I was a chemist I still
am a chemist and I really didn't have an
appreciation for the hugeness of the
human genome compared to say a five
thousand base pair plasmid that I was
using as a sort of a model system
and and I was thinking of this method it
would require a couple of Olga
nucleotides and one of them to sort of
be a control but they would be pointed
right toward each other just like in a
PCR reaction and and then I and I was
thinking of how many rid of excess
deoxynucleotide triphosphates is
something like there was a couple
technical problems I was trying to saw
often one of them the way I was gonna
decide to solve it was to till I run a
sort of sham reaction first with the
oligonucleotide in place in the sample
and then then then I had my radioactive
traces and stuff and run it again and
because I was gonna use up though it was
just not for monthly I didn't at first
look like duplicating the signal but
then I realized the side effect of that
was gonna be that I was going to double
the signal if there were enough like
deoxynucleotides available I was trying
to get rid of those if there were any
coming in with the sample but you were
out driving I mean you had this in your
head and you were thinking about it
constantly and then you'll just realize
that there is a way you don't think in
the last as much you know I usually
usually think I was spending my weekends
up in Mendocino at a little cabin and I
would drive up every Friday and I hadn't
come back on Sunday night and that's
really that was a nice it was about two
and a half hours and it's sort of you're
you're just you've got something to do
with your hands and you can't do
anything else until you think that's
that's when I did most of my thinking
actually because the day-to-day life in
a laboratory doesn't allow a lot of yeah
it's all these letters in your inbox and
there's your phone ringing and there's
always people that you have to deal with
and seven you don't have really that
kind of time
you
[Music]